everyone on a dietitian or is that  chipotle I'll show you so on the bottom  there I did half white rice because I  prefer white rice to Brown but I don't  love a lot of rice and I find that a lot  of these burrito bowls tend to be just  like basically mainly rice so I want to  leave extra room for some beans and some  extra veg in there then for my protein I  did black beans and chicken for some  healthy fats I did the guacamole and  they were very generous with the guac  and of course double down on the fajita  veg and the lettuce so I have lots of  fiber in there as well oh and I can't  forget the cheese because cheese is life  it is awkward trying to eat this in my  car but we'll manage  hmm